on the pharmaceutical strategy which is
the second pillar
of the european health union let me
first express
my hope that you're all following this
press conference in good health
i'm very happy to tell you that the
strategy will be presented today by vice
president sukinas and by commissioner
kirakires
as usual they will make a few opening
statements and then
we'll be happy to take your questions
vice president please
thank you um today together with uh
commissioner kevis we are proposing
a new pharmaceutical strategy for europe
it is a strategy that aims at ensuring
affordable
safe quality innovative and solutions
oriented pharmaceuticals for all
citizens
in the eu by presenting the strategy
today
we are also honoring the commitment made
by president van der lyon
both in her political guidelines
and in her state of the union speech in
september
today's package is
yet another building block of what
we call the eu health union
it follows our work the package that we
adopted on the 11th of november
where we proposed to modify
the statutes of our health agencies
the european center for disease control
ecdc and the european medicines agency
where we also reinforce
the crisis management aspects of our
work
and this package also adds to the
incredible work that we have been doing
on vaccines
and will be followed early next year on
the
on our cancer action plan so as you see
we have building blocks solid building
blocks emerging
to build this health union
for those of us who have any historic
view
of eu health policy uh
the work of the thunder lion commission
in our first
year of office is something
akin of a small miracle
uh we are doing things that would be
unimaginable
five or ten years ago who would have
told
uh people at the time
at the moment would come that europe
would pre-purchase
vaccines for all europeans from all
companies
producing them or about to produce them
we are exploring
every inch every centimeter of our
competence under the treatise
to make this work because we know that
when it comes to health
people want europe present
not accessory in health policy
of course i'm not discovering the the
will when i say that the pandemic
was also an accelerated in all this work
because it clearly showed us our
limitation
relating to data availability the supply
of medicines
our manufacturing capacities in the eu
and the production of medicines
we do not want to see
never again the problems that we faced
during the first weeks of the pandemic
never again
and with this pharma strategy we take
the first meaningful step
to avoid this from happening again
the package that the commissioner will
present in more detail in a while
has three main strengths
first is i like this word because it's a
greek
word it's anthropocentric
it centers on people on patients
we are sport we are responding
concretely
at what patients needs and when patients
need
and what patients need is real and
affordable access
to medicines secondly
we are balancing this also with
support to eu pharma
industry these proposals would allow
us to boost the competitiveness and the
innovation potential
of one of our very strong industrial
arms
the european pharmaceutical sector
and finally our proposal addresses
one of the key lessons learned from the
pandemic
probably the lesson of the pandemic
which is the need for europe to build
open strategic autonomy
we need to be able to rely on ourselves
not on others and
um let me say and conclude a few words
on on
on the patient-centered nature of the
strategy
as i was saying our aim is to deliver
for patients by
fulfilling unmet medical needs and
ensuring accessibility and affordability
of medicines
we want to prioritize research and
development
incentivize innovation including on
neurodegenerative neurodegenerative and
rare diseases and cancers
and we will invest a lot by
not only investing but also on breaking
regulatory silos
that have been a traditional problem
in this area and modernize this
legislation
by improving medicines and supporting
generic
and biosimilar medicines which are
cheaper
to conclude overall
with our today's package we are
addressing
the ongoing trends by building a
pharmaceutical sector that is more
respectful
of the green transition we're making the
most of the new technologies
and acknowledging that longer lives of
europeans
create further needs for medicines and
long-term care
at the same time with this strategy
we're addressing persisting
weaknesses systemic weaknesses and those
accentuated during the pandemic
to be better placed in the future should
we
find ourselves in the unfortunate
situation we are now
let me finish by highlighting a final
but
very important element
with the adoption of this strategy we
will be
completely overhauling
the entire legislative framework about
medicines from our certificates and
they're placing in the market
at the european union this is a set of
rules
that is 20 years old and it badly needs
modernization but this will be
a long process today is only the
beginning
of this vast chantier concrete proposals
will be presented not only the next two
years
but this is a strand of work that will
take us basically throughout the mandate
of this commission
our ambition is to leave behind
a solid modern eu legislative frameworks
for pharma
and ladies and gentlemen this would
allow us
once again to affirm that the eu union
for health
is not just a sound bite or a slogan
it is a reality it is an emerging
reality and we can now say
with confidence that we have the first
building blocks that would allow us to
defend
that the eu needs more cooperation more
coordination
and definitely more eu centrality and
presence
in this area thank you very much
still over to you thank you first of all
may i start on a personal note
and say how really um happy i am
that i find myself here today at this
press
uh conference with vice president sinas
uh having re
recovered and recovering from his recent
covet 19 experience it's good to have
you here next to me at the podium
margaritis
so good afternoon to to you um
all we have often said that
having universally affordable accessible
medicines
is not just something that we should
be working towards but it is a
fundamental
right for patients and for citizens and
this is what
we are here to present and share with
you today because we will be sharing
with you today
a pharmaceutical strategy uh that will
be
as the foundation of our work over the
next four years
now covet 19 has really shown us the
importance
of of having affordable and accessible
medicines especially in a case
when health systems are under pressure
but i i was
um i remind myself and thus all
that uh having a pharmaceutical strategy
developing a new pharmaceutical chat it
was in fact in my
in my mandate letter one year ago
which seems of course so much has
happened since but it was something that
was already
uh understood and demanded by the
european parliament by the council
that we needed to move in a different
direction in terms of a strategy
for pharmaceutical as in in europe and
covered 19
clearly showed us that the necessity
we have also seen how much we can
achieve
through our emblematic work on vaccines
when we use innovation
when we use technology when we give the
right incentives
how we can move quickly forward
and we as regulators and this has really
been
um for myself as commissioner for
health and food safety a key priority
from the very beginning
so the pharmaceutical strategy for
europe is our response
to the vulnerabilities that we have seen
highlighted by covet 19 but i would say
not only because we knew that these
issues
affecting affordability accessibility
and shortages of medicines
were already issues that were
very important to member states this is
a strategy that
will be able and aims to deliver
at all times for patients for an
industry
and this is important that we'll
continue to be a world leader
and the european champion and this is a
strategy that will be
one of the cornerstones of our european
health union ladies and gentlemen there
are currently over 7
000 citizens
in the eu living with rare diseases
including many of them with rare cancers
and it's a shocking number to know that
95 percent
95 have no treatment option
and what this means is that these
patients
and their families have to
live with the reality of not being able
to be released from
pain or having access to a cure
many of these also involve children
because we're talking also about
pediatric cancers
and there is nothing more devastating
than to
have knowledge that you are facing a
rare disease
or a very serious disease and you either
have no medicines that you can turn to
or that there are medicines out there
but they're not you're
they're not they're not accessible to
you so we need to do a great deal more
and we need to put
things um down now
at the same time what we saw with uh
covert 19
was the actual impact of antimicrobial
resistance we've discussed it so many
times before
and we have said so many times before
that over 33 000
people die from antimicrobial resistance
every year
but covet 19 really highlighted the
serious issues
to do with this and lives are lost
because the market is failing because we
don't have the development of newt
anti-microbials
there are too many patients and citizens
in the eu
today in 2020 that are still suffering
due to an absence of
of treatments we're losing lives
and at the same time the eu is a global
leader when it comes to pharmaceuticals
in research alone medicine producers
contribute to research and development
with over 37
billion euro they provide over 800 000
jobs and generate over 110 billion in
trade surplus so
our pharmaceutical sector is strong
we already do have a a
a good level of care in many areas of
the eu but we can deliver more and we
can deliver better
we need to look at innovation because it
is at the center here
we need to use digital transformation
and scientific
breakthrough we need to use promising
treatments
we need to move we're at the time now of
personalized care
we're at the time now when we need to be
able to use
gene and cell therapies and
regulators need to we need to look
as regulators to see how
we can move forward so that
we look at the boundaries that need to
be in place now and what has been put
not what has been put into place
uh over the uh the past many years
now i will not repeat what uh uh vice
president china has already said it will
be
based on four pillars on competitiveness
and innovation
in order to make personalized treatments
more available to patients it will
act focus on access to affordable
medicines
because really in fact innovation only
makes sense
if it is available and affordable to
patients
and it will also um be looking at
an european strategic economy by
ensuring supply chains
and addressing shortages in europe and
we saw how this was challenged in covet
19.
we have already launched a dialogue on
this
to have a clear understanding of the
supply chains and the shortages
and we will be looking at an ambitious
reform of our legislation
by 2022 and finally we need to ensure
that the
we maintain a strong voice in the global
stage
and the level playing field and this is
also included in the strategy so
ultimately in ending i would say that
what the pharmaceutical strategy aims to
ensure
is that europe is a place where
medicines are developed
manufactured made available in an
affordable
way to all patients to who need them
regardless of where they live in the eu
we cannot do this alone the commission
cannot do this alone we need the support
of member states
of the european parliament of ngos of
patient organization
but ladies and gentlemen i've stood at
this podium
countless times over the last few months
when dealing with this pandemic crisis
and i have heard and
shared with you the many expectations
the many concerns the many anxieties
that we need to do more in the area of
public health
in our union and that's why we presented
eu for health
that's why we went forward and presented
the european health union
and that is why we're going to be
shortly coming forward with the europe's
beating cancer plan
because we have been listening and we're
listening to european citizens
and um all these are parts of the
european
of the new european health union one
that is citizen centered
one that will be patient-centered and
one that will deliver what
citizens expect from us so today's
strategy
is to build a stronger europe in the
area of health
and is it is another step in
what we want which is to deliver what
citizens expect from us
especially at the time of crisis thank
you
thank you commissioner thank you vice
president we'll now take questions
i see that laura had a question on
skiing holidays laura i will take this
question
a few moments but i will first give the
floor to your colleagues
who may have questions indeed on the
pharmaceutical
strategy so let me maybe first give the
floor to david carretta
david go ahead
uh thank you very much in fact it's a
question on vaccine i don't know if
i can go ahead yes go ahead go ahead
thank you very much
[Music]
italian radio the first question is on
on
on backside and and the strategy uh you
have put forward
some weeks ago you have asked
member states to present national plans
and you have promised to make an
evaluation of those plans
i'm wondering at what point at what
point
we are in this evaluation do you think
that for example italy is ready
uh since there are news of
problems with needles and so on
and if you think that you should
[Music]
deploy vaccines so also in countries
where
authorities are not ready to to proceed
to
a big campaign of vaccination
vaccination and the second question uh
it's on
the issue of the ski season because the
italian government
has asked the commission to act to
coordinate or to make some decision
also for other member states and i'm
wondering if you
you have anything to say on that issue
thank you
okay thank you
now on the issue of the backs on the
issue of the vaccination plans of member
states
yes vaccines are important safe and
effective vaccines are important but
what is actually
crucial is vaccination and it is this
this is the reason why since october we
started working with ecdc and member
state
in order for them to have their
vaccination plans into place
and europe needs to be well prepared for
this vaccination
this means that member states cease to
have the necessary infrastructure and
the logistics so when there is a safe
and effective vaccine they can roll it
out and deploy it as quickly as possible
from the information that i have is that
all member states
have so far responded on the development
of their covert 19 vaccination plans
six member states have so far published
the recommendations of the priority
groups that they will be
vaccinating and around half of them
have provided information on the
logistics of their deployment but we're
working on that constantly
you must understand that this is not
something that is we
that will happen uh uh and
it's not static it's an evolving
situation that we're looking at
constantly with member states
because what we want is that when a safe
and safe
and effective vaccine is authorized to
ensure that member states will be ready
so um this is the current situation we
have also provide
moved forward with
joint procurements for large-scale
vaccination supplies in order to support
member states
for this in terms of other countries i
think there was a question
for that i wasn't sure i think the other
question was on the skiing
situation oh the skiing situation
well i i'll say what uh
what we have said before uh since april
when we presented the road map in april
for the
um
on the phasing out of containful
measures
now i we all know we can all see
from from our everyday lives that the
lifting of restrictions too early can
lead to
an increase of the number of cases
this approach still applies today there
is no one-size-fits-all
a different member states have different
realities
so we need to have a gradual i would say
science-based and effective way of
lifting containment
measures until a safe and effective
vaccine is available
and we are able to vaccinate the
critical mass of the population
we are urging member states to continue
their efforts to mitigate this pandemic
because this is the only way forward and
in this way they need to continue with
their actions on preparedness
on testing on contact tracing we have
put out guidance for this
and this continues to be in in place
thank you thank you
thomas thomas go ahead
um uh also a question for commissioner
kiriyakiris
on diversifying the supply chain and
the council and the parliaments are
saying for years now that the eu needs
to do this
um so now you will have another dialogue
with the industry i've spoken to several
people in the industry
who are saying we don't have another two
years it's just
going to be too late please come up with
these regulations
now why does it take another two years
it takes another two years because we
need to know exactly how we're going to
move forward
first of all in order to be able to
address the issue
of shortages and supply chains and the
disruption you need to be able to
understand what the root causes are
this is why we have already launched
a study in order to understand and see
the root causes
and after we are able to do that then we
can come up with proposals
so um in fact one could say
why are we coming forward with this
strategy now because we need to start
early immediately
we already have left it it has already
been there
for too long and now we're moving
forward with this now so
uh what i would say is that uh in order
to be able to change
the pharmaceutical legislation i know in
order to be able to address
these issues which have been there um
for a very long time
we need to be able to understand the
root causes and come forward with
proposals that will last into time as
well
thank you natalia
you have to adjust your mic source
apparently
you yes you hear me now yes we hear you
welcome
okay hi good afternoon commissioners i
wanted to ask on the
on the strategy um and especially on the
shortages and the um
what do you what do you want to do on
diversifying a supply chain
i wanted to know if you could elaborate
a little bit more on on
on this intention to to to diversify the
the the sources especially on raw
materials for
for medicines because in this strategy
you mentioned that
for example that africa might be an
important partner to cooperate
on on on this field so i wanted to know
if
your intention is to bring closer the
production
of raw materials uh critical for
for some medicines thank you
i probably have a go on on shortages in
general and then the commissioner may
come in
on on the more specifics of raw
materials and
diversification we said that the main
objective of
the strategy is to ensure that medicines
are available to patients in need at all
times
not only in normal times but also in
times of crisis
that clearly exposes our vulnerabilities
and that's what we saw in the first
weeks of the pandemic
without the right medicines at the right
time we cannot
treat diseases or conditions or provide
life-saving medication
but the causes uh for shortages
are not com are not easy
to understand and are not unidimensional
if i may say so they're
complex and to address them we need
to have a very clear overview of the
challenges of the issues at stake you
mentioned some of those
so to be able to attack at the sources
of the shortages we have launched the
major study precisely to
better understand the root causes of
medicine shortages and this is a study
that we expect to
have finalized next year but that will
not stop
our work to continue addressing the need
for continuous supply
for the companies and what would the
requirements be for that
and as i was telling you earlier
this is the first step we are now
opening a process that would bring us
down to legislative
specific legislative initiatives
and this might include applications of
supply
earlier notification of shortages and
hence transparency of stocks
anything that we can front load to allow
us to act
earnest yes
uh thank you i'll just add to what uh
vice president zinas said just
on the second part of your question vice
president hinas and i both in our
introductions
uh spoke about the strategic autonomy
and are
um i want to be clear here that
protectionism is
not in the dna of the european union
um that said our open strategic autonomy
is a major political objective of this
uh strategy and i would say it's also a
lesson learned
from the covet 19 crisis and i
personally
know what this means when we had
export bans from third world countries
and found out that we were dependent on
apis and other medicines totally from
from from other parts of the world so
we need to move in a different direction
but
we will of course be remaining open to
trade
but we need to get a better
understanding of the supply chain and
understand its vulnerabilities
assess and then be able to move forward
um
uh with the changes that we need to do
so i hope that this answers the question
under the general issue to do with
shortages
i'll just add that um it's a very
complex issue and this is why
as vice president hines has said we've
launched a study on this
but what i want to show you is that
patients remain at the center
of this process and the valuation thank
you
thank you susannah fexus please go ahead
the floor is yours
thank you suzanne fresches as i see
express portugal
actually i have a follow-up question
uh to david um for a
question following what david said
because in the
in the communication of the 28th of
october
the commission says that the first
review on national
vaccination plans will be presented in
november 2020.
so actually i'd like to understand if
you are still going to
publish this review with the more
details
um well compared to what you just said
and this leads me to a second question
because uh
well we are almost in december and you
still don't have
those vaccination plans that you asked
a month ago so those countries that
still don't have a vaccination plan
are still already late and are you
worried about this
when we're dealing with an unprecedented
health crisis and
we're dealing with a pandemic i would
never say i'm not worried about anything
i've learned to be alert and to be able
to respond to challenges
but what i would say is that we do have
feedback from all member states
we do have feedback from all member
states we we went forward in october we
asked them
for their feedback by november we do
have the feedback
from from the member states ecdc will be
publishing its feedback in the coming
days and weeks
and what we also need to understand is
that
this is an ongoing situation this is not
something that
we will suddenly have the data and we
stop monitoring it you need to have the
data you need to monitor it you need to
see it's implemented
and you need to follow it up this is not
finding a safe and effective vaccine or
having authorized
is one small important vital hopeful
step
in a huge chain of events and we are
going to be looking at this
24 7.
if i may add to what the commissioner
just said
this morning the president in parliament
of course she
mentioned the need for member states to
now
start organizing the vaccination plans
but
i think susana that under no
circumstances this should be interpreted
as a political argument of attacking
those who haven't done yet
because it's a bit like the
the dog that bites its tail uh i have
followed a bit this debate
and many member states that were very
early
in presenting their national vaccination
plans
they also got criticized for doing this
without having the vaccine in place
so we should avoid to go into a
situation where
there will be a an assessment board or
who is too early or who is too late
as the commissioner said what matters
now
is for all these plans to be in place
we have assured an extensive a
formidable portfolio
for all citizens in the eu from all
potential vaccines that are doing well i
think that we should now
concentrate on on delivery because it's
very clear
that what saves lives and what will
ultimately slave lives
is not vaccines is vaccination
thank you thomas milierina
the floor is yours
your mic is not working we see you but
we don't hear you
we still don't hear you
it's good to see you but with sound it
would be better
john said anything with the mic no
otherwise i'll take the next one
thomas there seems to be a bit of a
problem we still don't hear what i
suggest this will will come back to you
or otherwise you can send your question
in the chat box and i will then go to
the next
colleague maria maria go ahead
hello hello to all of you i have three
questions by may
first for the what by vice president
said about
the europe's strategic autonomy
uh how can this happen in commissioners
said that it is political choice first
of all
so my question is we have seen at least
two
european councils via teleconference for
coordination we have seen councils
trying to coordinate
member state states and still today we
have
different restrictions measures between
the eu countries and
there's no a common you know view about
what will happen increase
during christmas time so what exactly do
you mean
by a strategic autonomy the second
question is for commissioner cliakidis
every year you said
around 33 000 persons
die because of antimicrobial resistance
because companies think that it is not
profitable
how can this change and the third
question if i may
last one i promise um today commission
president
said that european citizens will start
to be vaccinated
before the end of the year can you
elaborate a little more on that
i mean when do we expect
the first vaccinations on the european
territory
thank you thank you maria have a go at
the autonomy part and probably
commissioner take
care of the vaccination and the other
question on the autonomy um
i said uh well it's not me that i said
it but it's i think universally
acknowledged
that this is probably the main
lesson of the pandemic that
europe should be at all times
normal times but also crisis times to be
able to rely
on a certain capacity when it comes to
not only personal protective equipment
but also medical equipment
raw material drugs pharmaceuticals it's
important it's vitally important
that we are planning ahead it's
i mean we should not hide behind our
figure
to say that this did not was not the
case at the early stage
of the pandemic um we
and i use the the we in the broadest
possible sense
that we found out that no one was
practically manufacturing
mosques in europe that uh
many raw materials were produced at a
rate eight percent out eighty percent
out of the european union
we were struggling for ventilators we
were
facing export bans between our member
states
so all this is what we need to change
this is not rocket science uh the call
for eu
strategic autonomy is precisely that
to make sure that we have the capacity
the resources
to identify what we need act quickly
act in a coordinated way play
as a team and
i'm confident that this is now emerging
uh i
i don't there say is a certainty but i
think
as a as a point of convergence between
uh
all our member states the final point i
think the commissioner said it earlier
no we do not see this call
for eu strategic autonomy as
a backdoor to protectionism we will do
we will not do that
this is not the european way we have in
the european union
35 million jobs depending
on exports so we are very aware
of the parameters of this operation but
we are also very
hopeful and encouraged by the political
winds
that are very favorable to move in that
direction
to two other questions that maria raised
one was amr i had also uh mentioned it
in my opening
remarks it is indeed a major threat we
know we have known that and it's a major
threat globally
and i have always also called on other
global
partners for example last week i had a
call with the australian minister
because everybody needs to be part of
this in order for us to tackle amr
there is one of the reason that
uh uh we have a difficulty with uh
with a with uh antimicrobials is uh one
that
several reasons one of them is overuse
and misuse
and the other one is that we have a weak
and uh
challenging businesses who don't
want to invest in in new antimicrobials
so the strategy will be addressing this
in two ways
one to reduce the use
and of antimicrobials rather than misuse
and encourage appropriate use of
antimicrobials and secondly
to incentivize the development of new of
new antimicrobials
and we'll be doing this with both
legislative and non-legislative measures
for your um a second question of course
yes
president fonda lyon uh said that we we
could start vaccinating by the end of
this
uh of of of this year by by the end of
december
um we are waiting uh
to see when the different
companies will be submitting their files
to emma for assessment
and all being well once we have
the assessment and of the dossiers
we will be not at the cost of safety at
any time
moving as quickly as possible in order
to be able to
have the emma assessment
in the in the coming weeks after
the doses are submitted but this depends
crucially
on when companies submit their dossiers
to emma
so that
if there are any questions whether
whether that has already been done as
far as
my information is until today we
so far haven't had submissions
thank you and i see that thomas has
managed to send us his question through
the chat box sorry about
the my problems he has three questions
i have noticed the reference to the
european defense fund as one of the
funds that could promote innovation in
the pharma sector
does this mean there's a concern for the
defense and security implications
of pharmaceuticals and vaccines second
question is there any progress in the
possibility that
members of the european parliament from
the health committee be given some
access to the vaccine agreements
negotiated by the commission
in exchange for non-disclosure
commitment and then finally but i think
thomas this question has been replied to
you asked about the ski question but as
commissioner aquidas has replied to that
question
so there's a question about defense
aspects of
the pharmaceuticals and vaccines and
giving access to some members of the
parliament
yeah i will take the the first question
because the
reply is is very short the answer is
yes obviously there is a link
because uh availability and
accessibility of pharmaceuticals
is is is a issue of clearly uh
strategic uh importance
it has a direct link to our security not
only to our prosperity and to longer
lives and we will mobilize
everything we have to make
the resources available to achieve our
goals
including the defense fund
on the parliament the commissioner knows
a lot
on the parliament of course we have said
before that we cannot
legally disclose information which is
contained in the pro
contracts which is protected by
confidentiality clauses
but of course we are when i say this
fully accountable towards all the
european institutions
and the european citizens and i can
assure you that we're acting in full
compliance
with all applicable rules within the
cons
contractual constraints and i have
already said this when i was in
parliament
a week ago we are ready to explore
making information from the contracts
available to nominated members of the
parliament with specific
arrangements once the sensitive ongoing
negotiations are concluded
yes of course if i may add the final
touch to to my
reply which was redid very short so that
thomas has the fullest picture
thomas we're having in on the 15th of
december a major package
on security and
some of the things that i can say now
very uh succinctly
we will be able to analyze and present
in more detail in our package of the
15th of december
namely the links with security thank you
vice president thank you commissioner
and with this we have come to the end of
the press conference i would like to
thank the vice president commissioner
i would like to thank the interpreters
who are always doing an astounding job
um thank you very much stay healthy and
we'll definitely be in touch bye
yes
you